ravi de vous retrouver sur public sénat
cet après midi c'est michèle alliot
marie ministre des affaires étrangères
qui sera face aux sénateurs dans
l'hémicycle elle est interrogée par
bariza khiari sénatrice ps de paris sur
l'avenir de l'upm l'union pour la
méditerranée je vous rappelle que cette
institution était co présidée jusqu'à
présent par nicolas sarkozy et hosni
moubarak l'ancien président égyptien
michèle alliot-marie de plus en plus
fragilisé par les révélations du canard
enchaîné sur la transaction immobilière
qui auraient lieu entre ses parents et
l'homme d'affaires tunisien aziz miled
mais aussi par la confirmation
aujourd'hui d'un entretien téléphonique
que michèle alliot-marie aurais-tu fin
2010 avec l'ancien président ben ali
tout de suite je vous propose donc de
prendre la direction de l'hémicycle pour
suivre cette séance qui s'annonce animé
très bonne fin de journée à tous sur
notre antenne l'état madame bariza
khiari pour le groupe socialiste auteur
de la question pour 20 minutes
merci madame la ministre monsieur le
président mes chers collègues
c'est dans un contexte international
inattendue il y a deux mois deux mois
encore que s'inscrit cette question sur
l'avenir de l'union pour la méditerranée
en décembre dernier laissant les
chancelleries se demandait s'il serait
possible de te dit de tenir le sommet de
l'upm en avril prochain
aujourd'hui cette question est caduc et
nous devons tirer parti de ce vide
institutionnel pour questionner les
principes qui pourraient nous permettre
de refonder un véritable projet global
méditerranéen
il s'agit d'une question sensible pour
les français nous avons un lien affectif
lié à l'histoire ancienne et récente
avec les pays du maghreb et du machrek
sans compter une part importante de nos
concitoyens ont des liens avec la rive
sud
cet intérêt pour la méditerranée à des
ressorts complexe et ambigu au delà même
de la référence à la latinité et à l'
empire monde de fernand braudel
l'imaginaire méditerranéen se nourrit de
l'orientalisme et aussi de la
fascination française pour le
nationalisme arabe qui a été le
principal vecteur de la décolonisation
dans le temps qui m'est imparti
j'aimerais revenir sur le paradoxe
méditerranéen
le projet politique de l'union pour la
méditerranée et enfin les contradictions
de la politique méditerranéenne de la
france et de l'europe
j'ai eu l'honneur d'être élue vice
présidente de l'assemblée des
parlementaires de la méditerranée la
paix m cette assemblée réunie les
parlementaires nationaux des pays
riverains de la méditerranée y compris
israël les palestiniens israéliens
c'est donc de l'intérieur que j'observe
les paradoxes méditerranéen tous les
discours sur la méditerranée emprunte au
registre de l'histoire et du lyrisme et
jc dre brièvement en évoquant cette
citation anonyme et évolutive qui
rappelle que l'alphabet phénicien le
concept grecque le droit romain
le monothéisme sémites l'ingéniosité
punique la munificence bisontine la
science arabe
la puissance ottomane la coexistence en
daluz la sensibilité italienne
l' aventure catalane et la liberté
française et l'éternité égyptienne mais
ni l'histoire ni le lyrisme ni
l'invocation répété à la marine ostrom
ne peuvent avoir raison d antagonisme
fort qui structurent les relations
bilatérales régionales et multilatérales
de la région par ailleurs c'est moins
l'histoire que l'avenir qui doit guider
notre action en la matière en vérité la
méditerranée a toujours été une terre de
conflit quoi de plus logique pour cette
région qui bordent trois continents qui
a vu naître les trois religions
monothéistes et qui se situe à la
frontière du nord et du sud est au
confluent des cultures d'orient et
d'occident les lignes de fractures sont
anciennes elles se multiplient se
renforce et se durcit les épisodes de la
décolonisation la guerre froide et la
mondialisation des échanges ont
transformé cet héritage commun en
anomalie politique en dépit de nos liens
humains et historique en dépit de la
multitude des structures de toute nature
qui vise à rapprocher les rives rien n'y
fait la méditerranée reste plus encore
que le rio bravo la frontière la plus
inégalitaire au monde inégalités
inégalitaire en termes de vie de niveau
de vie de pib d'accès à l'éducation
d'accès à la santé le niveau
d'investissements européens il reste
désespérément faible seuls 2 % de nos
investissements se font sur la rive sud
les échanges économiques entre les deux
rives sont donc très faible et les
échanges intra régionaux sont encore à
construire
j'y reviendrai le projet méditerranéenne
l'europe a lancé a été lancé par jacques
delors en 95 avec le processus de
barcelone qui s'appuyait sur l'histoire
l'importance stratégique de la
méditerranée et la nécessité d'une
coopération forte à même de contribuer à
la prospérité et à la stabilité
mais la coopération méditerranéenne dans
sa dimension politique a achoppé sur la
centralité du conflit
israélo-palestinien est aussi sur la non
résolution d'autres conflits dits
conflits périphériques comme celui du
sahara occidental alors qu'il aurait
fallu en tout l'utiliser tirer les
leçons de l'échec de barcelone la france
du candidat sarkozy
à avec sa maladresse diplomatique
constante voulu relancer le processus de
coopération dans le cadre d'une promesse
de campagne aux visées plus
électoralistes qu'humaniste dès le
lancement de l'idée en pleine campagne
présidentielle
l'accueil fut mitigé nos partenaires
européens et en premier lieu l'allemagne
ont vu dans ce projet une manoeuvre pour
donner une nouvelle impulsion à la
politique arabe de la france et dont le
coût serait financée par l'europe la
turquie y vit quant à elle une stratégie
pour lui barrer la route à tout jamais
de la vision européenne et les pays
d'europe orientale pour leur part
exprimé leur inquiétude de voir l'argent
européen s'y déverser à leur détriment
le projet initial retouchait de fond en
comble par allemagne dans le cadre de la
présidence française de l'union
européenne n'avaient plus rien à voir
avec le projet initial porté par
monsieur sarkozy et monsieur guaino mais
les apparences urs aux messieurs sarkozy
en grand illusionniste a eu une fois de
plus le talent de transformer le fiasco
politique de l'upm en succès médiatique
au final la brève histoire de l'upm peut
se résumer à une journée de splendeur le
13 juillet 2008 suivi de deux années
d'hésitation bureaucratique d'un trick
diplomatique et d'impuissance politique
deux ans et demi après ce lancement
grandiose et les espérances portait ce
jour là l'heure est venue de dresser un
bilan
nous savons d'ores et déjà qu'il est
inconsistant pendant deux ans des
négociations interminables ont porté sur
la répartition des postes le siège du
secrétariat général barcelone ou pas
barcelone
le financement qui paye quoi les
questions liées à la gouvernance
on est dans l'interview vernement talent
ou bien dans le communautaire le statut
du secrétaire général du secrétariat
général
elles n'ont jamais été réellement
trancher l'an passé les deux sommets de
sommet ont été reportés sine aidiez
aucune réunion ministérielle n'a donné
lieu à des engagements fermes
seuls les réunions dites techniques
étaient assurés et ce n'est que le 27
décembre dernier
il y a moins de deux mois que le site
internet de l'upm a été lancé et en
anglais seulement
enfin un numéro téléphone mais on a eu à
peine le temps de le composer que le
secrétaire général de l'upm le jordanien
ahmad massa'deh fonctionnaires éminent
des missions et l'actuelle révolution
égyptienne pose le problème du
remplacement de la co présidence de
l'upm détenu jusqu alors par hosni
moubarak de moribonde cette institution
est devenu en l'espace de quelques jours
fantomatique la france reprocher et à
raison au processus de barcelone de
fonctionner suivant des relations
déséquilibrées où l'europe décidé de
tout avec le pml a contribué certes à
créer une structure paritaire mais une
structure où ne parvient pas à savoir
qui décide de quoi
une première question madame la ministre
qu'allez vous proposer pour résoudre ses
faiblesses institutionnelles
pourtant les projets de l'upm projet qui
lui préexistaient sont toujours d'une
actualité brûlante
qu'il s'agisse de la dépollution de la
méditerranée du plan d'énergie solaire
de la prévention des catastrophes
naturelles de la création des autoroutes
de la mer ou de la création
d'universités mairie méditerranéenne sur
la rive sud
deuxième question madame la ministre
concernant ses projets ou plutôt de deux
questions dans une île ont pris
préexisté à l'upm vont ils lui survivre
et sous question dans le contexte actuel
de quels financements disposeront-ils
l'upm souffre donc d'un vice de
conception mais aussi et c'est sans
doute plus préoccupant d'absence de
vision de stratégie politique
l'upm pour fonctionner aurait eu besoin
de s'appuyer sur les ensembles régionaux
et en premier lieu sur la construction
d'un maghreb uni et fort au tour de
l'algérie et du maroc
les coûts du non règlement de la
question du sahara sont très élevés et
pèse politiquement sur la région ils
sont humains économiques et sécuritaires
des milliers de familles payent
l'absence de solution politique des
enfants grandissent dans des camps et
cette souffrance nourrit leur amertume
et leur désespérance et pendant que ce
drame prend de l'épaisseur de génération
en génération
la perspective d'une région intégrer
économiquement s'éloigne emportant avec
elle les opportunités économiques
ic frustrant des aspirations populaires
pour nous européens la persistance de ce
conflit qui déborde sur la zone
sahélo-saharienne constitue une menace
directe sur la sécurité euro
méditerranéenne et euro atlantique
nous en avons vu les conséquences
dramatiques avec l'enlèvement et la mort
de nos compatriotes
qu'avons nous fait nous français et
européens pour soutenir une solution
négociée entre les protagonistes de ce
dossier et tenter un tant soit peu
d'aidé aux côtés de l'onu à trouver une
solution politique à ce conflit qui
obère toute possibilité de ré de
développement régional qui empoisonne
les relations entre l'algérie et le
maroc et qui est si contre-productif
pour leurs populations respectives
inexistant sur de ce dossier nous
n'avons rien trouvé de mieux que
d'envenimer les relations déjà
passionnelle avec l'algérie avec la
funeste inscription dans notre loi des
effets positifs de la colonisation
et quant à votre gouvernement alors
qu'il existe un accord très aboutie de
coopération en matière de lutte contre
le terrorisme entre la france et
l'algérie
il a tout simplement porter l'algérie
sur la liste des pays à risque
terroriste
oubliant au passage que ce pays a été la
première victime de l'intégrisme
avant même de nommer les principes sur
le quai sur lesquels nous pourrions
relancé l'idée euro méditerranéenne il
faut que nous apprenions à écouter ce
que les peuples
on va nous dire ni la france ni l'europe
n'ont vu venir les mouvements sociaux
qui sont en voie de transformer la phase
politique de la rive sud
je ne parle pas de la brutalité de la
deffe la déflagration ni de l'irruption
de ce bouleversement radical qu aucun
stratège n'a vu venir
je parle de ces messages qui depuis
plusieurs années nous parviennent
quotidiennement des bateaux de fortune
qui sombre dans la méditerranée avec à
leur bord ni jeunesse préférant
laventure suicidaire à l'absence
désespérante d'avenir au lieu de prendre
toute la mesure de ses appels de
détresse
nous avons soutenu des régimes d'un
autre âge faisant l'hypothèse que ces
peuples ne serait décidée par eux mêmes
cette surdité et d'une certaine façon en
paf en parfaite cohérence avec la
théorie occidental
pour ne pas dire néocolonial sur la
démocratie impossible dans les pays de
tradition musulmane
la politique des pays occidentaux
s'appuie sur un prisme datant des années
affirmant que la seule alternative au
pouvoir autocratique et tu es
l'obscurantisme islamique comme si le
choix ne pouvait se faire contre le
pharaon et le barbu obsédé par cette
question
l'union méditerranéenne et la france ont
cautionné la privation des libertés
publiques
il faut revenir sur les raisons de cet
aveuglement qui perdure aujourd'hui
encore aujourd'hui encore si notre
diplomatie père soit correctement les
évolutions je veux leur rendre hommage
parce qu'après les magistrats les
policiers et bien d'autres professions
c'est au tour de nos diplomates d'être
stigmatisé le gouvernement semble déçu
de n'avoir trouvé nulle part dans les
pays musulmans en pleine agitation la
mesure intégristes on confond à mauvais
escient
l'islam politique avec le besoin de
spiritualité inhérent à la nature
humaine
ce besoin de spiritualité de sens qui se
renforce
ici comme ailleurs au fur et à mesure
que progresse la déshumanisation des
rapports sociaux
cette surdité explique la vision
partiale et partielle que nous avons de
la rive-sud et que sous-tend les trois
contradiction majeure de la politique
française dans son rêve euro
méditerranéen
la première contradiction consiste à
vouloir asseoir une nouvelle influence
française sur la rive sud tout en
stigmatisant sur la rive nord
jour après jour les citoyens d'origine
contrôlée que sont les français de
confession musulmane
les attaques menées par votre
gouvernement sur le sur le sol français
contre des musulmans est indigne de
notre conception de la laïcité et
corrosive pour notre vivre ensemble et
aussi notre image à l'étranger
cette croisade à commencer par
l'hostilité à l'égard d'une adhésion de
la turquie à l'europe
la création du ministère de
l'immigration et de l'identité de
l'identité nationale qui s'est
poursuivie par landing débat du même
et les polémiques sur la burqa les
minarets il reviendra elle la fièvre
obsidionale fut tel que pendant quelques
jours certains os sincèrement cru qu'une
chaîne de fast food
son aire de jeu ces sandwichs et ses
plateaux repas était la cinquième
colonne d'une invasion minutieusement
programme et tout cela a été le terreau
sur lequel le front national a pu se
refaire une santé et madame le pen fait
référence à l'occupation pour désigner
les musulmans et cela va continuer avec
le prochain débat sur le
multiculturalisme inscrire dans votre
agenda politique les français venus
d'ailleurs vont encore être les otages
de la prochaine campagne électorale
je vous fais grâce du discours de dakar
où malgré les prévenances d'un
ambassadeur averti ajustements licencié
depuis nicolas sarkozy a gravement
offensé les africains cette vision
fantasmée et anxiogène de l'islam et des
musulmans largement relayée et commentée
dans les pays du sud par les médias et
les réseaux sociaux justifie dans les
pays du sud
un discours symétrique de repli
identitaire ne vous y trompez pas les
populations de la rive sud sont
connectés au réseau moderne et
connaissent vos dérapages sur l'irak
nous avons su nous différencier fort
heureusement mais nicolas sarkozy en en
prenant en empruntant le chemin d'un
l'atlantisme bea a contribué à alimenter
la mécanique infernale du conflit des
civilisations théorisée par les
néoconservateurs américains
cette politique cette idéologie est en
totale incompatibilité avec un projet
méditerranéen ambitieux barack obama
avait ouvert une perspective de
dépassement aux américains avec le
concept post raciale et nous si proche
des pays arabes
nous n'avons pas compris que les jeunes
générations de musulmans étaient dans
une phase post islamique postis la mise
ils sont très attachés à leur
civilisation à leurs traditions et
veulent tout simplement vivre leur foi
dans un monde ouvert
ils ne se contenteront plus d'un ersatz
de démocratie car ils ont bien compris
que les attributs de la démocratie sont
bien plus large que le simple droit de
vote
ils veulent des libertés publiques
justice presse indépendante et les
garanties libertés individuelles il
souffre d'un déclassement et rejette les
nouveaux maîtres qui pillent leur pays
il y a également une demande sociale
forte la deuxième contradiction les
réside dans la volonté de créer une
union reposant sur des projets tout en
verrouillant par une politique des visas
malthusienne toute circulation humaine
c'est nord-sud jamais sud nord en
définitive la proche méditerranée de
méditerranée de l'europe se caractérise
par les objectifs sécuritaires et des
barrières migratoire la seule
coopération qui semble fonctionner et
celle entre les organes de sécurité et
les ministres de l'intérieur
ce n'est pas un reproche mais cette
coopération qui se content qu'ils se
concentrent sur les flux migratoires ne
permet pas de nous protéger
collectivement de la déstabilisation du
sahel là encore la construction d'un
ensemble régional aurait pu nous en
prémunir gelé déjà évoqué troisième
question au delà des postures politiques
des lois sur l'immigration
comptez vous offrir enfin un réel
partenariat migratoire offrant des
possibilités de migration circulaire aux
pays de la rive sud premiers jalons
indispensable à une véritable politique
méditerranéenne
enfin la troisième contradiction porte
sur la difficile articulation entre
l'objectif des droits de l'homme et les
logiques de puissance en effet la
définition d'un discours de politique
étrangère fondée sur l'universalisme des
droits et le soutien aux libertés
publiques se heurte de plein fouet à la
concurrence que se livrent les états
démocratiques pour développer ou
conserver leurs parts de marché dans
certains pays
cette realpolitik se donnent bonne
conscience en affirmant que du
développement économique découlera
automatiquement l'aspiration
démocratique mais la position française
va bien au delà de la realpolitik
elle n'est pas axé simplement sur une
efficience de la conditionnalité
politique
elle s'appuie et je le regrette sur la
négation de l'humanisme on sait le peu
de considération que porte le président
français à la question des libertés
publiques qu'il qualifie avec mépris
d'idéologie droits de l'hommistes comme
si c'était une maladie honteuse que de
se soucier de ses semblables
ce parti-pris s'est traduit ces
dernières années
par le tapis rouge pour certains et le
guichet fermé pour des démocrates
opposants et également par la
disparition rapide du secrétariat d'état
aux droits de l'homme par la mise au
placard
la secrétaire d'état ayant dénoncé les
dérives de la françafrique
la multiplication sur notre sol des
espaces de l'endroit la stigmatisation
liée à l'origine pour les roms la
sixième loi visant encore l'immigration
avec des atteintes à notre constitution
comme la déchéance de nationalité
fort heureusement rejeté par le sénat
dans sa grande sagesse mais il y à plus
grave encore que ce cynisme et ce mépris
ouvertement affiché la logique de
puissance la grammaire diplomatique
peuvent expliquer le silence d'un état
démocratique
mais elle n'implique en rien l'usagé de
l'hypocrisie de l'afad flagornerie
pourquoi le président de la république
française at il cru bon de saluer la
progression de l'espace de liberté en
tunisie alors que toutes les ong ne
cesse de dénoncer depuis des années la
verse la crédibilité internationale de
la france ne se mesure pas au nombre de
chefs d'état que quand une photographie
elle repose entre autres sur l'estiment
que les sociétés civiles de la rectitude
nous accorde dans le monde arabe
autant dire que cette crédibilité
n'existe plus en défilant
madame la ministre avec des pancartes
qui n'ont pour seul texte que dégagent
les manifestants tunisiens égyptiens
rendre peut-être hommage à la
francophonie c'est notre modeste
participation aux troubles
révolutionnaires le ce mot et le peu
qu'il nous reste de l'esprit de 1789 la
force de renvoyer à chaque soubresaut
régional les musulmans 1 giga de
fantasmer nous avons perdu en plus de
l'usaj de notre raison la grandeur de la
france
pourtant la jeunesse de ces pays n'est
pas dans la fascination du modèle des
modes des mollahs iraniens dont elle
connaît la brutalité
c'est au contraire répulsif pas plus que
de la copie du modèle occidental pour
d'autres raisons
elle observe avec intérêt la turquie qui
semble alliés démocratie développement
économique et valeurs islamiques
il faut bien admettre qu'à l'instar de
la démocratie chrétienne une démocratie
musulmane puisse voir le jour
c'est pourquoi avec beaucoup de gravité
je nous invite
à ne pas nous engager dans le coeur des
cassandre depuis trop longtemps les pays
occidentaux s'accommode des états
autoritaires au nom du péril intégriste
depuis qu'un barbu et cela devient
obsessionnel depuis qu'un barbu illuminé
et pyromanes se cachent dans des grottes
préhistoriques
après avoir défié les citadelles de la
modernité
madame la ministre si nous avons
décrypté ce que les sociétés civiles du
sud on va nous dire rien n'est perdu
pour construire une union pour la
méditerranée c'est pourquoi la france la
prochaine relance méditerranéenne
souhaitable et même inévitable ne pourra
faire l'économie d'une part d'une
nouvelle grille d'analysé entre quête du
religieux et projets politiques d'une
relation apaisée avec son passé sa
mémoire coloniale et ses citoyens venus
d'ailleurs et d'autre part devra renouer
avec son credo dans le progrès et
l'universalisme des droits quatrième
question et j'ai eu mon intervention
tire à sa fin
quelles leçons tirez-vous de
l'aspiration démocratique de la rive-sud
et comment comptez-vous à la lumière des
événements relancer le processus de
l'upm j'ai bien conscience madame la
ministre de porter un réquisitoire d'une
sévérité d'une grande sévérité sur le
fond mais il nous faut regarder les
choses en face et se dire la vérité
c'est à ce prix que nous pourrons
retrouver des liens de confiance avec la
rive sud que nous pourrons traiter
d'égal à égal et construire ainsi cet
espace méditerranéen dont nous avons
tous besoin
une belle idée a été gâchée nous sommes
convaincus socialiste en tout cas que le
destin de l'europe vieillissante est lié
au destin des pays du sud
nous sommes convaincus que nous ne
parviendrons pas à aucune coopération en
tout cas l'avenir sans respect
considération et solidarité avec ces
peuples les foules delà de la place
tahrir et de tunis scandent leurs
espoirs dans leur pays mais aussi dans
leur région allons nous enfin les
entendre et leur proposer un cercle
vertueux gagnant gagnant que j'appelle
de mes voeux
je vous remercie
merci chers collègues dans le débat la
parole et à monsieur robert hue pour le
groupe crc spg pour dix minutes sur le
président madame la ministre d'état mes
chers collègues en egypte un large
mouvement populaire vient de chasser du
pouvoir un dirigeant honni
même si personne ne peut aujourd'hui
prédire l'issue de cette insurrection
cet événement nous concerne et doit nous
faire réfléchir sur le rôle de notre
politique étrangère
dans cette région les révoltes sociales
les luttes pour la démocratie de ces
dernières semaines en tunisie et en
egypte ont clairement mis en lumière
l'échec des ambitions euro
méditerranéenne du président de la
république ce qui devait être l'un des
grands chantiers diplomatique du
quinquennat est devenue vide de sens
cet échec sert également de révélateur
aux faiblesses de notre politique
étrangère depuis plusieurs années et à
la dégradation de l'image de la france
dans les pays du maghreb du machrek mais
également au proche orient
ironie ou vengeance de l'histoire lors
de la création de l'union pour la
méditerranée en 2008
le président de la république avait
insisté pour que le siège de
l'organisation et son secrétaire général
résident à tunis il n'avait pas obtenu
satisfaction mais il avait pu se
consoler en co président l'upm jusqu'à
ces dernières semaines avec hosni
moubarak
il en faisait ainsi notre partenaire
privilégié au delà des troubles que
connaît la région
le coup de grâce avait déjà été donné à
cet institut
sion par la démission de son secrétaire
général et le retrait forcé de son co
président égyptien
la démission de monsieur ahmed massa'deh
a été un nouveau coup dur pour l'
influence de notre pays dans le monde
arabe
l'ancien secrétaire général avait
justifié sa décision par sa lassitude
face à la paralysie de l'organisation
faute d'orientation claire et de
possibilités d'accords entre les
différents pr pays sur des projets
concrets
mais ce qu'il y avait surtout en
arrière-plan de cette démission
c'est l incapacité de notre diplomatie
animée par le président de la république
a donné les impulsions nécessaires à
l'union pour la méditerranée souvenons
nous pourtant qu'en 2008
le président de la république croyait
pouvoir tirer les enseignements de
l'enlisement de la politique
méditerranéenne de l'union européenne
appelé processus de barcelone
il avait alors pris l'initiative d'un
mouvement de coopération avec les pays
de la région malgré les réticences de la
plupart de nos partenaires européens en
créant cet espace de coopération
il ambitionnait aussi sans doute de
donner à l'europe un poids suffisant
pour influer enfin sur le processus de
paix au proche orient
il voulait tirer parti d'une influence
certaine dû à notre proximité historique
et culturel pour promouvoir les
principes et les valeurs de la france au
moyen d'une nouvelle politique de
coopération
le candidat sarkozy n'avait-il pas en
effet promis une diplomatie des valeurs
vous entendez des guillemets durant sa
campagne pour l'élection présidentielle
n'avait-il pas déclaré le soir même de
son élection que je le cite la france
sera du côté des opprimés du monde de
tous ceux qui croient aux valeurs de la
liberté de la tolérance et de la
démocratie
hélas
les actes n'ont pas suivi les promesses
à la lumière de ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui nous voyons bien que notre
pays risque de payer cher de lourdes
erreurs stratégiques de sa politique
étrangère
le président de la république n'a pas su
trouver le juste équilibre entre la
diplomatie les enjeux économiques et les
droits fondamentaux
c'est ce qui fait aussi que les
opposants tunisiens égyptiens ignore
totalement et rejette parfois l'upm trop
associés à leurs yeux aux anciens
présidents ben ali et moubarak
ceci a largement contribué à
décrédibiliser le rôle que notre pays
revendiquent dans cette région et à
altérer l'image de la france auprès des
peuples qui paraissent ne plus rien
avoir à attendre de nous ni de l'europe
sans vision stratégique
votre politique diplomatique dans ce cas
précis c'est fait au jour le jour au gré
des événements il s'agissait selon le
vieil adage britannique d'attendre et de
voir notre incompréhension du processus
historique de seb dans ces pays
notre incapacité à prendre position et à
réagir face aux événements en cours
explique par la conception strictement
néolibérale que votre gouvernement comme
les dirigeants européens se fait de la
coopération avec les pays de la rive sud
de la méditerranée
en effet vous concevez l'aide économique
de ces pays comme le moyen d'assurer un
certain type de développement sans me
semble-t-il vous préoccuper des
conditions sociales et politiques dans
lequel il se réalise
l'histoire nous apprend pourtant qu'il
est illusoire de penser qu'un
développement durable économique social
mais aussi culturelle puisse se réaliser
sans la démocratie
votre conception c'est celle des agences
de notation qui ont immédiatement
baisser la note de ces pays lorsque les
intérêts des puissances économiques
étaient menacés vous
ainsi rassurer à bon compte de la
stabilité garantie par des pouvoirs
corrompus qui opprimait leur population
pour préserver un ordre économique et
social qui servaient leurs seuls
intérêts et les protéger vous vous êtes
laissé aveugler par l'épouvantail du
fondamentalisme religieux musulmans ils
n'ont cessé d'agiter afin de se
présenter comme un rempart contre celui
ci on découvre malheureusement
aujourd'hui la triste réalité de ces
manipulations
on apprend par exemple que l'ancien
ministre de l'intérieur égyptien est
soupçonnée par la justice de son pays
d'être impliqués dans un odieux attentat
contre une église copte officiellement
attribué un mouvement terroriste
islamiste
tout cela vous a conduit à être peu
regardant sur la nature de ces régimes à
être complaisant avec ce qu'il faut
appeler des dictatures mais vous avez
aussi et peut-être surtout gravement
ignorer ou en tout cas sous-estimer la
colère de ces peuples contre les
injustices leurs aspirations mais aussi
leur capacité à édifier des sociétés
démocratiques
permettez moi de rappeler que notre
groupe avait dénoncé déjà à dénoncer
l'absence de prise en compte de cette
dimension majeure que sont les droits
fondamentaux à l'occasion du sommet
fondateur de l'upm à paris au mois de
juillet 2008
dès cette époque nous critiquions la
différente
la différence de conception entre
l'union pour la méditerranée et le
processus initial de barcelone qui bien
que fondée sur une politique libérale de
libre-échange liait développement
économique et lutte contre la pauvreté
et fixait des exigences en matière de
droits fondamentaux
nous avions également relevé que le doc
que le docteur moncef marzouki opposant
au régime de benali devenu aujourd'hui
populaire en tunisie nous renvoyait à
nos propres exigences afin de garantir
la réussite d'une nouvelle politique
méditerranéenne je le cite
aurait-on pu
envisagez l'élargissement de l'europe à
l'espagne au portugal ou encore à la
grèce du temps des dictature de franco
salazar et des colonels grecs
aujourd'hui que reste-t-il du projet
mort né de l'union pour la méditerranée
en deux ans et demi d'existence le bilan
de cette institution est aujourd'hui
très minces il a débouché sur des
accords sur l'énergie solaire le trafic
maritime les transports routiers et en
avril 2010 sur une conférence sur l'eau
sans véritable suite rien de concret que
dans tout cela seulement une succession
de séminaires ou d'études déconnecté des
réalités économiques sociales et
politiques
certes ce bilan décevant ne peut être
uniquement imputé à votre conception
erronée des conditions dans lesquelles
doit se réaliser le développement des
sociétés
il y a aussi des raisons objectives qui
font qu'aucun projet ne peut aboutir
tant que ne sont pas régler des conflits
ou des désaccords entre les différents
acteurs de la région je pense
naturellement au conflit entre chypre et
la turquie entre le maroc et le sahara
occidental est bien entendu au conflit
israélo-palestinien qui fait de la
coexistence entre israël et les pays
arabes
l'un des principaux problèmes posés pour
l'union pour la méditerranée donc cela
ne pourrait être possible qu'au prix
d'une légitimité nouvelle au prix d'une
profonde redéfinition notre politique
euro euro méditerranéenne des aides au
développement des pays de cette région
dans un sens qui soit favorable à leur
peuple et non aux seuls intérêts du
libéralisme économique
c'est à cette révision profonde que je
vous avais madame la ministre d'état
invités à procéder en vous questionnant
il ya quinze jours en pleine tourmente
tunisienne vous m'aviez alors répondu de
façon que j'ai ressenti comme agressive
et inapproprié aujourd'hui le président
de la république le gouvernement et
vous-même prennent le train de
l'histoire
malheureusement je pense en marche
pourtant nicolas sarkozy semble encore
marqué quelques réticences à reconnaître
son incapacité
comprendre vraiment ce qui se passe dans
ce pays alors que vendredi dernier
il saluait entendez les guillemets le
courage dont aurait fait preuve
hosni moubarak en démissionnant il est
donc grand temps pour la france et pour
l'europe de tirer les enseignements de
ces événements et de revoir radicalement
leur stratégie dans cette région et je
termine l'europe et plus généralement
l'occident qui ont trop longtemps tenu
ces peuples pour mineurs et soutenu
leurs dirigeants et leurs dictateurs
doivent aujourd'hui aider par tous les
moyens
ces processus démocratique dans le
respect de l'indépendance des états et
des choix des peuples
il leur appartient notamment de soutenir
leur développement économique leur
développement économique et social
conditions essentielles et je termine de
la pérennisation de ces démocraties
naissantes jeu ce sont ses exigences
pour terminer que le coprésident de
l'upm également président en exercice du
g20 le président sarkozy devrait
entendre pour mettre en oeuvre de
nouvelles orientations
merci chers collègues la parole est un
monsieur jacques blanc pour le groupe
ump pour dix minutes
ce président madame le ministre mes
chers collègues je voudrais dire à
macquarie qui est l'auteur de la
question qui nous permet de débattre
d'un sujet passionnant passionné et
difficile que c'est un peu dommage que
son réquisitoire
et surtout été centrée sur une attaque
que je respecte
par rapport au président de la
république parce que j'ai plaisir à
participer avec elle à l'assemblée des
parlements dans la méditerranée mais
chacun doit bien mesurer que ce dossier
qui n'est pas née meyer vous l'avez
rappelé l'histoire
roh méditerranéenne est déjà ancienne
je ne le reprendrait pour ma part que
depuis 95
car il faut pas oublier que le processus
de barcelone est née après les accords
de 93 d'oslo qui avait ouvert une
perspective une espérance de paix entre
israël et la palestine et que c'est dans
ce contexte qu avec un rôle majeur de la
france d'ailleurs lui espagne ce
processus avait été lancé j'ai eu le
privilège en tant que président du
comité des régions d'europe d'assister
tour de la conférence direct a quand
même des moments où rencontrant le
ministre des affaires étrangères
d'israël et le responsable de palestine
beaucoup d'espoirs ont été fondés alors
certes ce processus n'a pas abouti à ce
qu'on pouvait attendre mais il a quand
même jalonné l'histoire des rapports
entre europe et méditerranée
il a permis que se dessine un certain
nombre de perspectives des accords de
libre échange et qui ont pu être
installés ces stores et suppression des
barrières douanières de l'union sur des
produits manufacturés exporté début
d'une zone de libre échange entre maroc
tunisie egypte jordanie c'était les
accords d'agadir création d'un outil de
l'europe en faveur des pays
méditerranéens
certes qui a un peu déçu mais qui a eu
le mérite d'être créée
c'est le meddat création du femi
c'est-à-dire facilité méditerranéenne et
d'investissement de partenariat des
opérations qui se sont concrétisés
ensuite ont pu être lancées avec
un jeux d'hiver soit globalité d'
approche méditerranéenne soit opérations
bilatérales alors ce pour évoquer de
gazoduc transsaharien le tgv tanger
casablanca
il ya des opérations quand même
concrètes mais c'est vrai que ce
processus avait besoin et je n'oublie
pas aussi les problèmes environnementaux
qui ne sont pas nés à barcelone puisque
l'onu avait lancé le plan bleu pour la
méditerranée mais qui a été relancé à ce
moment là mais c'est vrai que ce
processus avait besoin d'être boosté en
quelque sorte relancer et je crois que
les mérites du président sarkozy qui
n'était pas encore président c'est
d'avoir perçu cette dimension
exceptionnelle pour l'union pour la
méditerranée est d'avoir osé lancer
relancer le processus de barcelone en
lançant l'union pour la méditerranée
alors ça a été un peu difficile parce
que les autres pays européens étaient
pas très chaud ils avaient peur un peu
d'une union qui n'aurait concerné et
c'est le cas à l'assemblée des parements
de la méditerranée que les pays
méditerranéens et ils ont tenu à ce que
l'europe
il participe c'était quand même une
volonté politique et qu'il fallait
intégrer ce qu'a fait le président de la
république puisque union méditerranéenne
est devenue l'union pour la méditerranée
après l'accord avec madame merkel
c'était d'autant plus important il faut
bien le dire que cette politique
euro-méditerranéenne impliquer la
politique de voisinage qui en matière
européenne avait besoin et a toujours
besoin d'ailleurs d'évoluer avec la
dimension globale régionale
venant compléter la dimension
bilatérales europe et
pays candidats à la politique de
voisinage et donc on a assisté à ce
mouvement qui s'est incarné c'est vrai
en juillet 2008 par la présence à paris
de l'ensemble des responsables à ce
sujet d'ailleurs des débats ont été
ouverts à la suite de la président
présence du président syrien
et à ce sujet je veux dire que président
de groupe france syrie notre ami ialma
chargée de dire ici combien ils
pensaient que à la fois la dimension
globale méditerranéenne mais aussi les
rapports bilatéraux des actions
bilatérales pouvait donner un contenu
supplémentaire à cette politique
alors aujourd'hui c'est vrai 1 la paix
entre israël et la palestine
elle est installée est ce qu'on peut
expliquer que c'est la faute au
président sarkozy
écoutez soyons quand même on est chacun
oui mais en fait on a un peu insinué bon
chacun sait bien qui a une mobilisation
que c'est un sujet extrêmement difficile
et que gaza et la colonisation
la reprise et colonisation par israël
n'a pas facilité les choses
il faut quand même le dire est qu'on ne
peut pas à rendre responsables la
diplomatie française mais aujourd'hui
après ce qui s'est passé ce qui se passe
en tunisie et j'ai participé au groupe
d'amitié france tunisie je pense sous le
contrôle du président sueur où nous
avons condamné la mesure devait
impression là bas n'est ce pas
c'était avant le départ de monsieur ben
ali dont je suis à l'aise pour en parler
mais ce qui se passe en egypte et en
tunisie
est-ce que ça rend caduque
l'union méditerranée au contraire mes
chers collègues et moi je dis que plus
que jamais ça rend d'actualité le besoin
de renforcer une politique euro
méditerranéenne peut-être que ces jeunes
où c'est moins jeunes qui ont manifesté
leurs espérances
d'une liberté nouvelle peut-être que le
message de l'union méditerranée les a
confortés dans leurs démarches et
peut-être que notre responsabilité
aujourd'hui c'est de dire mais au
contraire
devant cette aspiration des peuples à la
fois à la liberté au respect des droits
de l'homme ou développement car
n'oublions pas l'importance aussi du
développement économique pour cette
jeunesse en particulier
eh bien peut-être qui nous appartient
aujourd'hui d'afficher et d'affirmer
plus que jamais l'exigence d'une
politique euro-méditerranéenne renforcer
je dirais même un vrai plan marshall
pour la méditerranée pour répondre à ses
attentes
et pour que soient mobilisés et mis en
oeuvre une politique méditerranéenne
alors c'est vrai que les rapports d'état
sont toujours difficiles et le mérite
peut-être dans l'union méditerranée
c'est de s'ouvrir aussi sur ces
coopérations sous étatique
j'ai contribué avec mes collègues au
comité des régions d'europe à la mise en
place de l'arlem c'est l'association des
régions et collectivités locales
méditerranéenne où des élus du nord et
du sud se retrouvent se raconte se
rencontrent peuvent parler au delà même
des rangs problème des rapports d'état à
état
j'ai eu le privilège et un m²
le cdh être le rapporteur du problème
d'eau à l'assemblée des parlements dans
la méditerranée le dernier rapport à
rabat que j'ai proposé y avait le
président de la knesset et de vice
président de l'autorité palestinienne
qui dans ce contexte quand même
difficile était présent et donc le fait
de parler ça veut pas dire qu'on
cautionne l'interlocuteur ça veut dire
qu'on respecte les uns et les autres
le fait d'échanger le fait de compléter
la démarche des états par une démarche
de coopération sous étatique
ça peut être aussi un atout pour faire
passer des messages
alors il ya de grands projets à côté on
les a évoquées pour la mise autour de la
mer le problème d'énergie avec des plans
solaires avec aussi la boucle
méditerranéenne qui permettrait de créer
une dynamique nouvelle en trouble entre
tous les entre tous les pays des
problèmes concrets
je dois dire que vient d'être annoncé la
création d'un fonds alimenté avec eux
quand même une dimension
alors on n'est pas encore au milliard
qui était peut-être attendu jeu les
chiffres là mais en fait pour ne pas
être trop long il ya aujourd'hui une
perspective des échanges se sont
multiplié et je voudrais en terminant
dire mes chers collègues
c'est à l'heure des attaques internes
c'est l'heure du message que de cette
tribune nous pouvons apporter à
l'ensemble des pays méditerranéens et en
particulier à cette jeunesse ou à tous
ceux qui tout à coup voient une
espérance
peut-être se concrétiser alors disons
vous respecte c'est le mérite d'ailleurs
du processus car dans le processus de
barcelone
il y avait trop europe et pays lie à la
parité
créons cette dynamique et répondons aux
attentes de ces peuples méditerranéens à
leur disant nous respectons vos choix
nous comprenons vos attentes et nous
sommes prêts à nous mobiliser pour
apporter des chances supplémentaires de
réussite pour l'ensemble de cette
jeunesse qui attend de nous et de
l'europe des signes très positifs alors
libérons-nous des problèmes internes
pour ne regarder que la chance que l'on
peut peut être conforté pour eux la
jeunesse méditerranéenne
merci 4 lei la parole est à monsieur
denis badré pour le groupe de l'union
centriste pour dix minutes sur le
président
madame la ministre d'état mes chers
collègues l'actualité internationale
nous amène tout naturellement à nous
interroger et à vous interroger mon âme
ministre sur l'union pour la
méditerranée avec de vraies questions
mais aussi si vous le permettez avec
quelques réflexions et des propositions
des bouleversements considérables secoue
plusieurs états de cette union pour la
méditerranée et on ne la voit pas agir
et on ne l'entend pas on ne sait
d'ailleurs même pas si son co président
hosni moubarak a été ou vont être
remplacés l'upm semble avoir disparu des
écrans alors même qu'on devrait pouvoir
attendre beaucoup d'elle elle n'a pas
été créé pour traiter seulement de
problèmes mineurs
on n'aurait pas soulever des montagnes
pour rien j'avais bien compris qu'elle
était lancée pour amplifier et donner sa
pleine portée politique au processus de
barcelone
elle a bien été clairement conçu pour
progresser sur toutes les rives de la
méditerranée sur des sujets de fond tels
qu'un développement économique social et
culturel durable la promotion la
démocratie ou la défense des droits de
l'homme et des libertés fondamentales
alors nous devons chercher à réunir les
conditions qui lui permettront de
répondre aux immenses attentes qu'elle a
révélées ou susciter attentes qui
s'expriment tous les jours avec plus de
force
même si à beaucoup d'égards la france
doit assumer une responsabilité
particulière quand il s'agit de la
méditerranée et spécialement du maghreb
elle n'est ni forcément ni toujours la
mieux placée pour s'exprimer en direct
les états unis voir la chine aurait elle
alors les coudes et plus libre
certainement aussi longtemps du moins
que nous refuserons de voir et
d'accepter les possibilités dont dispose
l'union européenne peut intervenir en
notre nom
malheureusement si l'europe commence à
s'organiser pour le faire savoir est
toujours bien timide
il ya là aussi beaucoup pas dire est
matière à réflexion nous regrettons
d'autant plus l'effacement d'une union
pour la méditerranée qui serait
précisément idéalement placé aujourd'hui
pour parler tout à la fois avec le poids
de l'europe et avec la force n'est de la
proximité voire de la complicité qui
devrait se développer entre ses membres
européens au nom
de toutes les rives de la méditerranée
dès lors qu'il s'attache à relever
ensemble des défis qui les concerne tous
les crises que nous voyons se développer
sont profondes
elle éclate du fait de difficultés
sociales et d'emploi
ce sont d'abord des crises de
développement donc des crises de fonds
pire leurs enjeux au plan régional et
mondial sont encore beaucoup plus lourd
le mot grec krisis peut se traduire par
instants décisifs
nous sommes au temps où s'ouvre l'avenir
autant de toutes les deux tous les
possibles
ce temps doit être aussi pour nous celui
des vraies responsabilités
les mouvements actuels peuvent en effet
être instrumentalisés par les
intégristes et les extrémistes doute
toutes obédiences qui spéculent sur une
déstabilisation générale du proche et du
moyen-orient
ces soulèvements populaires sont aussi
porteurs d'aspiration très forte
ils peuvent également conduire vers les
libertés et la démocratie
serons nous assez fort et suffisamment
solidaire tout autour de la méditerranée
à nouveau pour faire prévaloir les élans
qui unissent et non les forces qui
divise et détruisent oui une union pour
la méditerranée active et responsable
manque aujourd'hui
oui les promoteurs de l'upm avait fondé
leur démarche sur une intuition très
juste et s'il n'avait pas engagé il ya
deux ans cette démarche
ils sont est aujourd'hui urgent de le
faire jacques blanc le disait très bien
à l'instant
l'upm existe mais elle n'est
manifestement pas en situation
aujourd'hui de jouer le rôle qui lui a
été confié essayons donc de voir si et
en quoi elle peut être amendée afin de
devenir réellement efficaces sinon tout
de suite du moins pour l'avenir il
fallait que l'upm soient la sphère de
l'union européenne dans son ensemble et
non des seuls états de l'union qui sont
riverains de la méditerranée et qu'elle
soit ainsi à l'instar du partenariat
oriental de l'union européenne une
composante majeure d'une politique de
voisinage priorités de l'union
européenne c'était indispensable pour
garantir la cohésion de l'union
européenne confié l'est à certains de
ses membres et faire du sud un domaine
réservé à d'autres auraient portait en
germe une des faisans
un éclatement de l'union européenne une
vraie politique de voisinage qui prendra
évidemment des formes différentes à
l'est et au sud doit être une priorité
pour l'europe pour nous français cette
politique est appelée à relever des
affaires européennes et non plus des
affaires étrangères au sens large
j'ai donc la faiblesse de considérer
madame la ministre vous êtes ici au
titre de vos responsabilités
particulières européenne il est clair au
demeurant qu'impliquer l'union
européenne dans le devenir du bassin
méditerranéen peut être perçue par nos
partenaires du sud comme un gage
supplémentaire d'efficacité politique
il est également évident que l'upm ne
peut qu'être une organisation
intergouvernementale
on ne pourrait participer à la fois à 2
union l'une et l'autre de nature
communautaire mais il faut que cette
organisation intergouvernementale
affaire d etat soit aussi et très vite
la sphère des peuples même si la qualité
des relations personnelles des chefs
d'état représente un atout à ne jamais
négliger
il est essentiel de dépasser rapidement
une situation qui serait excessif
excessivement personnalisés et alors
forcément contingenté fragile il faut
aller vers une institutionnalisation par
nature plus durable à condition
toutefois et c'est essentiel que cette
institutionnalisation repose sur une
charte des valeurs nous voici au coeur
du problème
ou bien on feint d'ignorer les
difficultés réelles qui existe du fait
des complices des conflits ouverts que
nous savons où du fait de marges que se
donnent certains états vis-à-vis des
bonnes pratiques démocratiques ou du
respect des droits de l'homme et ne
pourront jamais aller à l'essentiel et
nous ne pourrons nous tourner ensemble
vers l'avenir sur la base d'une solide
confiance mutuelle ou bien nous
n'éludons pas ces questions majeures au
plan des principes et surtout essentiel
pour tous nos peuples
mais il faudra alors du courage et de la
détermination le chemin sera rude la
situation actuelle ne représente-t-elle
pas une opportunité pour choisir tout de
même ce chemin en réalité et quelle
qu'en soit la difficulté
avons nous un autre choix peut-être le
reporter à plus tard c'est le minimum
qu'on pourrait imaginer nous le
pourrions si nous étions certains que ce
chemin restera ouvert or rien n'est
moins sûr les peuples qui se sont
soulevés attendre pourront ils le faire
longtemps
en réalité le temps presse vous le savez
madame la ministre
puisqu'on m'avait permis de m'en
entretenir avec vous je suggère que
l'union européenne délègue tout
naturellement ces questions de
démocratie et de droits de l'homme au
conseil de l'europe dont c'est
précisément le coeur de métier dans son
rôle éminent l'union pour la
méditerranée fixerait ainsi les grands
objectifs politiques et elle marquerait
sa volonté d'aller de l'avant en
proposant des programmes concrets
équilibrée et durable de développement
et elle s'appuierait sur le conseil de
l'europe pour ce qui touche aux droits
fondamentaux
je note en passant que parmi les états
riverains de la méditerranée aujourd'hui
nos membres de l'union européenne la
turquie où les pays des balkans sont au
conseil de l'europe et que les autres à
un titre ou à un autre ont engagé où se
dispose à engager un dialogue avec le
conseil de l'europe pour être tout à
fait concret j'ajoute surtout que sans
attendre de futures crises ou un avenir
plus lointain
nous devrions pouvoir proposer dès
maintenant notamment à la tunisie et à
l'egypte les possibilités offertes par
le statut de partenaire pour la
démocratie
ce statut instituée par l'assemblée
parlementaire du conseil de l'europe
pour favoriser le développement d'un
dialogue interparlementaire orienté sur
la promotion des valeurs ce statut
auquel le parlement marocain s'est
d'ailleurs déjà porté candidat
nous pouvons également rappelé que le
conseil de l'europe peut offrir les
services de la convention de venise aux
états qui remettent où seront appelés à
remettre en chantier leur constitution
et sont nombreux je suis certain enfin
que notre session d'avril de l'assemblée
parlementaire du conseil de l'europe
sera l'occasion de faire des
propositions sur tous ces sujets notre
délégation française
en tout cas madame le ministre demandera
des peuples amis rencontrent aujourd'hui
d'immenses difficultés pour trouver leur
chemin vers la démocratie vers la
liberté
les défis qu'ils ont à relever nous
concerne également très directement le
temps n'est plus aux querelles
subalternes mais à l'imagination et à la
solidarité à l'émergence d'une volonté
politique partagée tout autour de la
méditerranée de cette méditerranée
berceau des religions du livre de la
philosophie de cette méditerranée qui
est après tout le berceau de la
démocratie
merci chers collègues
la parole est à monsieur simon sutour
pour le groupe socialiste pour dix
minutes
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues
permettez moi tout d'abord de remercier
notre collègue bariza khiari d'avoir été
dans cet ordre du jour réservé à
l'initiative d'une question morale sur
l'avenir de l'union pour la méditerranée
il est vrai qu évoqué la méditerranée et
plus particulièrement sa rive sud et est
et ses relations avec le continent
européen revêt un caractère tout
particulier madame la ministre
en cette période d'un côté nous pouvons
que nous réjouir des mutations en cours
d'abord en tunisie en egypte et demain
certainement dans de nombreux autres
pays
avec l'espoir de voir l'émergence de
grandes démocraties mais de l'autre côté
il faut bien l'avouer et nous le
regrettons la france et l'europe surtout
l'europe sont les grandes absentes de ce
processus nous sommes si proches et
pourtant si impuissants
si proche et si maladroit si proche et
si peu crédible si bien que mise à part
notre proximité géographique
qu'avons nous à proposer ou à dire en
tant qu'européens convaincu et élu d'un
département de la méditerranéenne
départements dits teyrannais je suis
d'ailleurs le premier à intervenir à
cette tribune d'un départements bordant
la méditerranée cet après midi je suis
certain je suis certain je suis certain
qu'il ne s'agit pas d'un simple d'une
simple question de proximité qui
pourraient être abordés comme certains
l'ont pensé par la mise en oeuvre depuis
2003 de la politique européenne de
voisinage
il s'agit bien au contraire d'un sujet
de civilisation d'une histoire commune
et d'un futur partagé je ne ferai pas de
rappel historique des relations entre
les pays du continent européen et les
pays du sud de l'aspic terranère
d'autres ici ou ailleurs l'on fait ou le
feront de manière brillante
cependant je tiens à vous sensibilisez
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
sur la nécessité impérieuse pour
l'europe et pour la france de construire
une communauté de destin avec les pays
rive sud de la méditerranée justement de
s'inspirer des échecs du passé pour ne
plus reproduire les mêmes erreurs
parmi ces erreurs il ya celle qui
conduit souvent les européens abordé la
question des relations euro
méditerranéennes la manière suivante
que pouvons nous apporter aux pays du
sud
que pouvons nous apporte aux pays du sud
il faut maintenant inverser les choses
et se demander que peuvent nous apporter
ce pays et que pouvons-nous nous
apporter réciproque maman car nous aussi
nous avons besoin du sud
de par nos relations historiques
géographiques culturelles économiques et
environnementales il y à une exigence de
construire davantage sur le long terme
dans un monde multipolaire seulement
limiter la coopération la dépollution à
la création d'autoroutes de la mer à
l'élaboration d'un plan énergie solaire
comme a pu le faire jusqu'à présent
l'union pour la méditerranée dont le
président de la république nicolas
sarkozy a été l'initiateur en 2008 a été
une mauvaise réponse à un succès limité
du processus de barcelone
tel qu'il avait été initiée par jacques
delors en 1995
si bien que lorsqu'on compare les deux
l'upm est le processus de barcelone
ce dernier malgré ses imperfections
était un projet de l'europe
un projet complet est fixé contrairement
à l'upm des exigences en matière de
droits fondamentaux
il n'ignorait pas les questions
politiques comme l'immigration le
conflit israélo palestinien ou encore la
lutte contre le terrorisme
l'échec de l'upm parce qu'après
l'annulation de son congrès qui devait
se tenir à barcelone le 21 novembre
dernier et la démission récente le 26
janvier dernier de son secrétaire
général monsieur ahmad massa'deh le
terme d'échec est malheureusement
appropriée et en revers retentissant
pour le président de la république parce
qu'un mélange précipitation et
inconstance comme souvent il a réussi à
abîmer une bonne idée il est d'ailleurs
à d'hui désormais que l'upm n'est plus
qu'une instance de coordination de
projets qu'elle manque d'ambition
pour un sujet majeur pour notre avenir
je me permets d'ajouter sans polémiquer
que dès le départ ce projet était mal
engagée les critiques formulées à
l'époque par les pays du nord de
l'europe
et ici même par les sénateurs
socialistes étaient pleinement justifiés
en effet d'emblée l'initiative de
monsieur sarkozy avait été lourdement
critiqué par l'allemagne et d'autres
pays de l'euro européenne qui tenait
alors à s'assurer que la nouvelle union
ne viendrait pas concurrencer l'union
européenne où le processus de barcelone
plus au sud les différences
d'interprétation des versions anglaise
et française de la déclaration de paris
ont donné lieu à des querelles sur la
participation ou non de la ligue arabe
aux réunions de l'upm des désaccords
sont aussi apparues sur la question de
la gouvernance
ils ne sont d'ailleurs pour l'heure
toujours pas résolue et
vraisemblablement pas près de l'être
à bruxelles l'union européenne s'est
immédiatement sentie mise à l'écart
grave faute
le processus de barcelone était un
projet de l'union européenne coordonnée
par la commission européenne
alors que lui et l'upm est avant tout et
seulement un projet intergouvernementale
né de l'initiative de certains membres
la commission européenne et les états du
nord de l'europe ont été réticents à
mettre en place un nouveau mécanisme
le parlement européen a lui-même à de
nombreuses reprises et est très critique
sur l'upm au delà du discours du
président de la république et de
quelques bonnes intentions force est de
constater qu'au niveau institutionnel
upm renforce l'intergouvernementalisme
et fait primer les intérêts nationaux de
chaque état participant au détriment de
l'intérêt commun supérieur cette logique
est récurrente depuis 2007 elle est la
source de nombreux échecs sur le plan
diplomatique
en voulant à tout prix à tout prix est
toujours occupé le devant de la scène
le poids de la france dans le monde
autant et c'est regrettable
irrésistiblement a reculé au contraire
de celui de nos voisins allemands en
particulier
enfin tout projet de cette envergure on
ne peut pas faire l'économie d'un volet
politique
ic et esquiver comme l'a fait l'upm les
questions de la promotion de la
démocratie
la question des droits de l'homme ou
encore de l'avenir d'israël et de la
palestine
aujourd'hui l'heure est venue de tirer
un bilan des expériences passées et de
ne pas renoncer à l'objectif historique
du rapprochement des deux rives de la
méditerranée
il n'y a pas d'alternative possible au
renforcement des liens du nord et du sud
de la méditerranée
si nous voulons pas devenir une région
périphérique l'union européenne et les
pays du nord de l'afrique et du
proche-orient en restant séparer
prennent le risque définitivement
marginalisée dans la mondialisation
nos économies sont très complémentaires
ce qui manque au nord notamment matières
énergétiques se trouvent au sud est ce
qui manque aux sus les technologies
l'agroalimentaire le nord là je parle
ici de co développement avec pour
objectif prioritaire l'amélioration des
conditions d'existence dans un ensemble
prospère la résorption des disparités
sociales économiques entre les deux
rives est prioritaire elle est majeure
pour notre avenir
les échanges doivent concerner également
les champs social médical culturel
environnemental éducatif
nous avons trop ignoré les sociétés
civiles des pays du sud
l'europe est frileuse au contraire de la
chine des états unis qui investissent
massivement le continent africain le
proche et le moyen-orient
il reste donc beaucoup à faire et s'il
faut être ambitieux et relancer le plus
rapidement possible les relations euro
méditerranéennes
il en demeure pas moins qu il faut aussi
preuve faire preuve de pragmatisme et
d'humilité car nous faisons pas souvent
assez preuve d'humilité
l'europe doit reprendre l'initiative
d'une alliance forte entre les deux
rives
l'échec d'une telle ambition pèserait
lourd en termes de conflits de
croissance économique de tensions
sociales de problèmes environnementaux
au contraire sa réussite permettrait de
fonder une aire de civilisation partager
et dynamique qui peut aider profondément
tout d'abord l'europe arrêt tout
ses propres problèmes accroître sa voix
et son poids dans le monde
améliorer sa croissance mais aussi les
pays du sud et de l'est méditerranéen a
progressé dans le sens du développement
économique et démocratique
je vous remercie merci cher que la
guerre la parole est un monsieur yvon
collin pour le groupe rds pour 8 minutes
monsieur le président madame ministre
mes chers collègues
la récente démission du secrétaire
général de l'union pour la méditerranée
qui s'inscrit certes dans un contexte
particulier de la chute des dirigeants
égyptiens tunisiens illustre néanmoins
les difficultés récurrentes d'une
organisation née dans la douleur et bien
souvent au bord de l'enlisement
aujourd'hui on peut dire que c'est la
poésie paralysie qui guette l'union pour
la méditerranée grâce à l'initiative
opportune de notre collègue bariza
khiari nous avons l'occasion de nous
interroger sur l'avenir de ce grand
partenariat entre les pays riverains de
la méditerranée la question est simple
l'union pour la méditerranée est elle
condamnée ce n'est pas si sûr mais il
est clair pour tout le monde
chers collègues que se profilent au
moins est là sans doute sa mise entre
parenthèses il est bien évident que nous
sommes tenus par l'évolution de la
transition démocratique qui s'effectue
respectivement en egypte et en tunisie
deux pays particulièrement mise en avant
au sein de l'union pour la méditerranée
certes la nouvelle donne politique si
elle porte l'union pour la méditerranée
au point mort a le mérite de remettre en
débat la question des droits de l'homme
évacué à l'époque de sa création
on peut d'ailleurs se demander s'il
enthousiasme manifeste des anciens
présidents ben ali et hosni moubarak
pour le projet d'union n'était pas
motivée par le fait de trouver dans
l'institution le moyen de sanctuariser
leurs régimes autoritaires
le processus de barcelone d'ailleurs
fixé des exigences en matière de droits
fondamentaux mais pas l'union pour la
méditerranée profitons en tout cas de
cette période de temps qualifié de
latence pour méditer sur les points de
blocage a paru bien avant le réveil des
peuples de ce secteur en effet le projet
lancé par le président de la république
en 2008 a connu dès ses débuts des
moments difficiles qui explique aussi
saône a tué état d'inertie l'idée de
nicolas sarkozy était noble il faut bien
le dire qu'ils ne restent pas d'établir
dans cette région un espace de paix de
stabilité de prospérité pour les peuples
des deux rives
mais il a manqué aux origines une
véritable constante concertation avec
l'ensemble de nos partenaires de l'union
européenne qui aurait sans doute des
mines et bien des crispations en amant
et mieux contribuer par la suite a
dégagé en berry table élan collectif de
tous les états membres en direction des
pays du sud bordé par la méditerranée
je ne vais pas ici refaire l'histoire
mais dans sa présentation le projet
français consacré l'échec du processus
de barcelone il a fallu déployer
beaucoup d'énergie pour venir à bout des
tensions intra européennes franco
allemande en particulier
c'est vrai qu'une partie des pays de
l'union européenne regarde vers l'est
tandis que d'autres regardent vers le
sud
pour autant aucun état membre ne doit
ignorer que la méditerranée est au coeur
de toutes les grandes problématiques des
décennies à venir
que ce soit l'accès à l'eau à l'énergie
la conservation de l'environnement la
question des migrations de la paix tous
ces défis lee le destin des pays situés
de chaque côté des deux rives
par ailleurs il est inutile de rappeler
également que la réalisation une vraie
dynamique économique régional centré sur
la méditerranée dans laquelle l'europe a
naturellement un pied constituerait
l'espace économique faisant contrepoids
aux puissances émergentes
j'ajouterai même qui serait souhaitable
d'aboutir à l'espace de coopération
économique qui retiendrait des décoller
des délocalisations de nos entreprises
lorsqu'elles seraient inéluctables bien
sûr dans cette zone plutôt qu'ailleurs
plutôt qu en chine par exemple cela
permettrait essaie de constituer une
sorte de stabilisateur à l'immigration
et j'en profite d'ailleurs pour demander
madame le ministre à ce que la question
des migrations
écarté des préoccupations de l'union
pour la méditerranée y figurent le drame
humanitaire qui se joue sur la petite
île italienne de lampedusa et vient une
problématique qui touche les deux rives
de la méditerranée
pour toutes ces raisons mes chers
collègues il me semble que la relance de
l'union pour la méditerranée plus que
nécessaire mais elle mériterait cette
fois ci un dialogue et une préparation
sans doute à 27
d'autant que trois présidents successifs
de l'union européenne seront assurés par
des états du nord de l'est de et du less
de l'ordre
dès aujourd'hui il est important que le
gouvernement français prenne des
initiatives pour convaincre nos
partenaires restés sceptiques que ce
depuis 2008 et qui c'est vrai n'ont pas
facilité la mise en place de la
gouvernance de l'union pour la
méditerranée si nous obtenons ce nouveau
souffle il restera toutefois une épine
et non des moindres celle du champ
géographique de l'union pour la
méditerranée
le périmètre a sa cohérence bien sûr
puisque les membres
ormis de l'union européenne doivent être
riverains de la méditerranée
mais ce qui est parfait sur la carte
l'est beaucoup moins nous le savons sur
le plan politique la présence au sein de
la même enceinte des chefs d'état de
gouvernement d'israël de la syrie du
liban ou de l'autorité palestinienne n
est pas comme vous le savez mes chers
collègues de nature à faciliter les
choses nous le savons tous le dernier
sommet de l'union sans cesse ajournée
suspendu à la reprise des négociations
israélo palestiniennes
pour contourner cet obstacle il faudra
sans doute fonctionner sur la base d'
ensembles sous régionaux peut être
pourquoi pas malgré toutes ces
difficultés mes chers collègues malgré
le délitement de sa configuration
politique l'union pour la méditerranée a
tout de même réussi à concrétiser
quelques projets sur le plan technique
et financier je pense en particulier au
plan solaire france graines à la
constitution du fonds inframed premier
pas vers la banque la méditerranée jean
et j'en profite pour souligner le
travail actuellement effectués dans le
cadre d'une mission par mon prédécesseur
au rdse pierre laffitte une mission
destinée à créer un réseau spécifique
pour développer l'innovation en orbite
année nous entendons bien sûr avec
impatience ses conclusions tous ces
projets méritent bien sûr d'être
poursuivie mais en oeuvre par la société
civile il leur est possible je l'espère
de continuer leur cheminement malgré les
soubresauts politiques qui gagne cette
région mes chers collègues au détroit de
gibraltar seulement 14 kilomètres
séparent le continent européen de sa
rive sud la france et d'autres pays
européens partagent une histoire commune
avec plusieurs pays du maghreb et du
proche orient
le plus souvent la relation fraternelle
a pris le pas sur les ressentiments de
part et d'autre la remise terrain il me
semble que nous avons tous conscience
d'une communauté de destin
mais sur l'échelle du développement trop
de différences nous éloigne c'est
pourquoi le rdc et le rdse est favorable
à la relance du processus mais nous
souhaitons pour cela une diplomatie plus
habiles et plus visionnaires qu'elle ne
l'a été jusque là et nous voulons
oublier parfois des sujets qui fâchent
oui nous voulons un espace où tous
partagent notre goût de la démocratie et
de respect des droits de l'homme
nous irons ainsi tous dans le sens de
l'histoire
je vous remercie nous quittons
l'hémicycle du sénat à suivre dans un
instant l'émission politique de la
rédaction de public sénat preuve par
trois avec ce soir comme invité le
sénateur maire socialiste de dijon
françois rebsamen
merci de votre fidélité et à très
bientôt